hi my name is cliff Hastings in this
video screencast is called the hands-on
start to Mathematica if you're new to
Mathematica or looking for a refresher
then you've come to the right place
today we're going to go over the basics
of using Mathematica so go ahead and
start by opening up Mathematica on your
computer
so you can work alongside me when you
first launch Mathematica you should see
the welcome screen from here you can
create a new Mathematica document called
the notebook by clicking new document
and then selecting notebook from the
drop down menu so let's get started by
making our first notebook together
when you create a new notebook in
Mathematica you'll see a plus sign with
a horizontal bar in the blinking cursor
this horizontal eye beam means that we
are ready to create a new cell the plus
sign is the cell insertion assistant and
clicking on it brings up a menu that
allows us to choose the type of input we
want so for a first example let's choose
other style of text and then select
title from the drop down menu and press
ok now you have a big blinking vertical
cursor in our document and let's type
hands on start to Mathematica once we
are done let's go ahead and press the
down arrow to move the cursor below this
cell and you'll see it turned into a new
horizontal Eyebeam so we're going to
create now a section cell using a second
method and we'll use the menu bar at the
top we will choose format and then style
and then section and we'll go ahead and
type entering calculations when you're
finished typing hit the down arrow key
again to put our cursor below that
section cell now a third way to create a
cell is with keyboard shortcuts you can
see some of those keyboard shortcuts
when you click the format menu and
select style so let's go ahead and press
alt 5 or command 5 you're on a Mac to
create a subsection cell and we'll call
this one freeform input this time go
ahead and keep your cursor inside that
cell hold down the Alt key or option on
a Mac and press the Enter key this will
create a new cell with using the same
type of information we just had so let's
go ahead and type Wolfram language then
hold down the Alt key again or option
key and press the Enter key to create
now a third subsection cell we'll call
this one palettes when finished go ahead
and hit the down arrow key and that will
put our cursor below that cell now we
are building this notebook we've made a
title we've made a section we've made 3
subsection cells let's make some text as
well so we'll go ahead and use that
keyboard shortcut again and
vault five for the subsection we'll use
alt seven to create a text cell and
we'll just go ahead and type this is
some text each cell is indicated by a
bracket on the right hand side of the
notebook and some of these cells are
grouped together now the different cell
styles in Mathematica follow a hierarchy
do I double clicking the parent cell
bracket for entering calculations it
will leave the content in the top cell
exposed but hide the material below this
small triangle on the bottom of the cell
bracket indicates there is material
hidden underneath and if you want to
show that information just double click
that cell bracket and it will expand its
contents Mathematica also automatically
changes the size or color or font for
different cell types to help
differentiate them the look of your
document is controlled by the style
sheet which you can change under format
and style sheet so let's go ahead and do
that and now we're gonna choose how
about slide show and water you can
explore the different available style
sheets on your own but for now let's
just change a style sheet back to the
original by choosing format and style
sheets and default you can also
customize any particular piece of text
for example let's select the text for
Wolfram language then we'll choose
format and text color and blue and if
you decide you want to go back to the
original style then just choose that
text again go to format and then clear
formatting
offers three main ways to enter your
calculations so the first is freeform
input freeform input is great for new
users who aren't familiar with the
Wolfram language in Mathematica because
it lets you enter input using plain
English commands so go ahead and click
your mouse under the freeform input
subsection we made and then click the
equal sign on your keyboard to create a
new freeform input cell then let's go
ahead and type graph y equals 2x minus 7
and then hold down the shift key and
press Enter or hit enter on your numeric
keypad when you hit shift + enter
together Mathematica sends your input
through the internet to our servers with
this freeform input style and then it
translates it to Wolfram language which
you can then see directly below the
input and returns the results in this
case the plot of the line if you place
your cursor over the Wolfram language
that was returned you should see a
little pop-up that says replace cell
with this input when you click on this
the freeform input is replaced by the
Wolfram language equivalent of your
input now we can start to make changes
so for example let's change the negative
7 to a negative 2 and then press shift
enter to see how it affects the graph
again when we're using the Wolfram
language we don't need the internet
connection when we're using the freeform
input we do because that's how it parses
that language into an actual input and
an output let's enter another freeform
input but this time we'll use the cell
insertion assistant so click the plus
sign on the left and select freeform
input then we're going to type integral
of cosine of 2x and press shift enter to
evaluate to the right of the freeform
input line you'll notice a little plus
sign when you click on this Mathematica
retrieves additional information about
the result from Wolfram Alpha that might
be of interest such as step by step
solutions or solving this indefinite
integral or a plot when you're done
exploring you can click the plus sign
again to hide those results
now let's click on the output and you'll
see the suggestions bar pop-up which
suggests some things you might want to
do next to hide this bar you can click
on the X icon and if you want to see it
again just go ahead and click on the
arrow one of the suggestions made by the
suggestions bar is to simplify our
results let's go ahead and click on this
option simplify Mathematica simplifies
our expression to cosine of X times sine
of X now let's click the suggestion plot
and we can see the results from that as
well so we started with a free-form
input and the suggestions bar helped us
simplify then plot those results without
us needing to know any Wolfram language
at all freeform input also gives us
access to a lot of data from Wolfram
Alpha let's go ahead and start another
freeform input cell by typing the equal
sign on our keyboard then type the
number of turkeys in turkey and press
the shift + Enter key together
Mathematica then connects to our servers
and returns that data back to you but
not only can freeform input retrieve
data from Wolfram Alpha it also lets you
do calculations with this data as well
so let's say I want to find the GDP of
Turkey divided by the number of turkeys
in Turkey Mathematica retrieves the
relevant pieces of data and then it will
compute that result
now freeform input is great for getting
started but using the Wolfram language
directly will give you the flexibility
and power to tell Mathematica exactly
what you want it to do the Wolfram
language is very powerful but to get
started you really only need to know
four simple rules so go ahead and click
your mouse underneath the Wolfram
language subsection we made earlier then
click the plus sign on the cell
insertion assistant and choose again
other style of texts and this time
choose item numbered so the first rule
is capital letters to start all function
names then go and hit the enter key in
that will create item number two and
type Phung
arguments are enclosed by square
brackets hit the enter key again and
that will use out number three and
number three is lists ranges in domains
are enclosed by curly braces one more
enter key and the last rule is Shift +
Enter to run the calculation now this
last one is really important because
Mathematica can also be used as a great
text editor as we've seen a little bit
so far so pressing the enter key by
itself will always just create a
carriage return Shift + Enter together
or the enter on your numeric keypad
tells Mathematica to evaluate some piece
of input let's go ahead and calculate
another integral but this time we're
going to use the Wolfram language in our
knowledge from the four rules above so
press the down arrow key to create a new
Eyebeam below that numbered list and
start typing the word integrate with a
capital i' when you first start typing
the function starts out a blue color
because Mathematica doesn't recognize
the function we've entered and it pulls
up a list of possible function choices
when you select integrate from the list
the function name turns black because
now this is a recognized function you
can click on the double Chevron's and
Mathematica shows you several possible
ways to enter this integral so let's go
ahead and select the second one to
calculate a definite integral and that
pastes in a template for us to fill in
so for the function f let's enter x
squared by typing X and then ctrl 6 to
enter the exponent to raise X to the
power of 2 go ahead and click tab on
your keyboard to go to the next
placeholder in the template and then
enter the function variable X then tab
again to enter the domain for X from
negative 10 tab to 10 now notice how the
function name integrate start to the
capital I what we want to calculate x
squared is enclosed by square brackets
and the domain for X is enclosed by
curly braces
when you're ready to compute this
integral then press shift dinner we
immediately get an exact result which is
2,000 over three okay now that we've
entered a few inputs using both freeform
input and now this integral using the
Wolfram language let's go on to a third
way to enter input in Mathematica and
use palates so go ahead and click your
mouse underneath palates then go up to
the menu and click palates and select
the basic math assistant this palette
gives you an alternate way to enter
things into Mathematica let's go ahead
and say we want to create about a
three-dimensional graphic under basic
command click on 3d then select plot 3d
this now gives you a template to enter
the function and the ranges with all of
the brackets and braces already filled
in all you need to do is then either
point-and-click to fill in the
placeholders or tab between them so for
the function let's go ahead and enter
sign with the capital S we need to do
sign of so a square bracket X and then
times Y you can either enter a space for
X space Y or X asterisk Y either one is
fine for multiplication go ahead and hit
the close square bracket and then tab it
to the first variable which is X and
then tab to the min value which we're
going to type negative capital P small I
for pie and then tab and then capital P
and I for the X values then go ahead and
tab to fill in the range for y which
will have go from from negative pi to pi
as well this time let's for the max
we're gonna use the actual button on the
palette and you can click on the pie so
either the function name capital P I or
the the palette entry of Pi either one
is the exact same way you can also enter
pi using a keyboard shortcut so let's go
ahead and go back to that minimum for y
of negative pi and hit negative and then
escape P I escape and that's also a
great keyboard shortcut for entering
things like the symbol pi as well now
let's go ahead and hit shift
enter and we should get the result of
that first 3d graphic
click to place our cursor at the bottom
of our notebook and then we're going to
press the keyboard shortcut alt for or
command for in a Mac to create another
new section cell and we're going to call
this basic calculations now Mathematica
will always give you the most exact
answer possible for example let's take
16 divided by 728 and evaluate that
calculation by pressing shift enter we
get a result of 2 over 91 if you give
mathematic and exact input it's always
going to return for you an exact output
reduced as much as possible now maybe
you're wanting the numerical
approximation so we can click numerical
value in the suggestions bar to get a
numerical results now notice the
function is capital in which means
numerically approximate and what we want
to numerically approximate is enclosed
by those square brackets if you want to
change the level of approximation to a
hundred digits we can simply add a comma
and 100 after what we are numerically
approximating and then reevaluate with
these shift-enter you can also get a
numerical approximation by providing an
approximate input so if you change the
input to 16 point 0 divided by 728
Mathematica returns the result as your
numerical approximation as well next
let's learn about variable assignments
we're going to create a variable called
a and give it a value of 5 by entering a
equals 5 now notice the variable a is in
blue Mathematica doesn't recognize that
variable yet but once you hit shift
enter to evaluate the cell the color for
the variable changes to black because a
now has been assigned that that value of
5 now you can use the assigned variable
for other calculations so go ahead and
enter 3 a plus 1 and then press shift
enter 2 evaluated and you get the
desired result of 16 that variable
assignment will remain while Mathematica
is running but you can remove it you can
use the clear command so enter clear
with a capital C so capitulate on the
function name square brackets around
what it is you want to calculate so you
want to clear a and then hit shift enter
to calculate now you can notice the a
has changed from black back to blue and
when you really a plus one Mathematica
gives you that result of 3a plus one or
one plus 3a as well all right so let's
say now you want to solve an equation so
type solve with the capital S and then
open square bracket and then we'll say
3y plus 12 is set equal to 0 now when we
assign the variable above we can use a
single equal sign because we are
defining a to be 5 in this case we want
to solve for y where the left-hand side
is set equal to the right-hand side but
just this one calculation so when we
were trying to solve and find the
solution for y we use two equal signs so
equal equals zero and then we want to
solve for y so type comma Y close that
square bracket and then we hit shift
enter and Mathematica will solve this
equation for y so a single equal sign is
used for variable assignment two equal
signs means to solve the right-hand side
so it is equal to the left-hand side now
a third point to be aware of is how to
define functions so let's go ahead and
define our own function we're going to
make a new input cell we're going to
type F open square bracket X underscore
close square bracket and then colon
equals x control 6 make an exponent 2 so
f of X is set to x squared so F is our
function name the square brackets around
those function arguments the X
underscore is a placeholder for
something that has this specific pattern
the colon equals in Mathematica means a
delayed assignment so the right-hand
side of the delayed assignment is what
we want this function to do now when you
press shift enter to evaluate it you
won't get a result because all we have
done at this point is to define that
function but now we can ask man that
Mathematica to compute for example F of
2 so we type F open square bracket
to close square bracket hit shift enter
and we get the result of four now you
can also define multiple argument
functions if you would like so for
example let's type G open square bracket
X underscore and then comma y underscore
close that square bracket we're gonna
use colon equals for this delayed
assignment and then we'll say X control
six to the Y power now if you energy to
the 10 comma 10 so G open square bracket
ten comma ten close square bracket and
then hit shift enter Mathematica returns
that result of 10 billion we can also
use our own function with built-in
functions like solve so let's try solve
f of X equal equal 36 comma X and close
that square bracket and then we should
see that either six or negative six will
satisfy this equation
so while Wolfram language commands are
capitalized you can see you can use any
combination of upper and lowercase
letters for your own functions that you
create as well
let's go ahead and place our cursor at
the bottom of our notebook it will
create a new section cell by going up to
format and then we'll choose style and
section and then we will type basic
graphics and then hit the down arrow key
to make a new horizontal Eyebeam for a
new cell now to create our first graphic
in this section we're gonna use that
freeform input so type the equal sign
using the keyboard and then let's type a
graph of sine a parenthesis X close
parenthesis and then press shift enter
and as before we get back the Wolfram
language command that we could invoke
directly along with that result as long
as we have that internet connection to
take our freeform input and then make a
result for us so let's go ahead and add
a label to our plot now one of the
choices on the suggestions bar is labels
well click on that and by doing so that
will open up an interactive menu let's
label the plot sine of X and then click
done and let's do another one as well
this time we'll create something in 3d
so let's go ahead and and go to a new
cell and then we're going to type plot
3d with a capital P and a capital D
we're going to open square bracket we're
going to plot 3d sine with a capital S
and then another open square bracket X
control six to tip say x squared and
then plus so we're get out of the
exponent by hitting the right arrow key
and then hit plus y control six to make
the second exponent of Y squared right
arrow key out of that exponent close the
square bracket and then hit comma open
curly brace for our lists ranges or
domains they need to be in curly braces
so we're going to say X comma negative 3
2 3 and then close curly brace comma
open curly brace Y comma negative 3
comma 3 close curly brace and closed
bracket go ahead and hit shift enter and
then we should get that 3d graphic from
that now in these 3d graphic can
rotated by clicking-and-dragging so if
you click and drag while holding down
the Alt key or command key on the Mac
you can also zoom in and out of that
plot you can also hold down the shift
key and then click and drag which will
pan the image around the cell let's go
ahead and change our 3d plot to a
contour plot by just changing the
function name from plot 3d to contour
plot capital C and capital P so any new
word of a function name they all get a
new starting capital letter and then go
ahead and hit shift enter to reevaluate
now if you move your mouse over the
contours on the contour plot you'll see
little tooltips pop up to show the value
of those contours
take your mouse click at the bottom of
the notebook to make a new horizontal
eye beam and then on using Windows hit
alt 4 on your keyboard or command 4 run
Mac to make a new section cell and we're
gonna call this new section interactive
models go ahead and click down or use
your down arrow key to make a new
horizontal eye beam and let's type a new
2d plot we're gonna type plot with a
capital P open square bracket sign with
a capital S open square bracket X close
square bracket so so far we've said plot
the sine of X where so comma X so open
curly brace X comma 0 comma 2 and then
let's go ahead and use the palette to
click on the pie button
so we're saying go ahead and close the
curly brace and close the bracket so
here we've said we're gonna plot the
sine of X where X goes from 0 to 2 pi go
ahead and hit shift enter on your
keyboard and we get that result we want
to actually change this into an
interactive model in the function to do
that within Mathematica is called
manipulate so let's make a new cell and
we're going to type manipulate with a
capital M open square bracket and let's
copy and paste that plot command we did
earlier into that manipulate cell now we
need a parameter that we're going to
manipulate so let's introduce a new
variable right before the X and the sine
of X and we're going to say frequency
times X so frequency space X or
frequency times X now I'm going to
delete that asterisk you'll see if you
don't do that this is now just a string
or a variable called frequency X so you
must to indicate multiplication use the
space or use the asterisk now once we
have this we need to also tell
Mathematica what frequency is we're
gonna go to the very end of our input
click our mouse type comma and then open
curly brace and say frequency goes from
1 to 5 and then close the curly brace
and close the final bracket hit shift
enter and we've made our first
manipulate model where we have a slider
where we can see how frequency affects
this sine curve
now let's make a another one let's go
ahead and use that same input but this
time we're going to replace the function
sign with a new variable called function
so with a small F because that's our own
function name so we're going to define
function after frequency we're going to
define it as the list of sine cosine and
tangent now we can hit shift enter and
we can see we have a slider for both
frequency as well as buttons for sine
cosine and tangent now the great thing
about Mathematica is you can manipulate
anything you can calculate let's make a
new cell and we're going to type
manipulate again this time we're going
to manipulate and expansions we're going
to type open square bracket expand with
a capital e and then we're gonna expand
the quantity of y plus Z to the nth
power so control six to make that
exponent and then we're going to right
arrow key out of that and say in goes
from two to 100 in steps of one and then
close the brace and bracket hit shift
enter and then we should get our
manipulates so we can see how the in
exponent changes this expansion now
making these interactive models is is
quite simple as you've seen but there's
also a huge repository of pre-built
models that are freely available on our
website at the Wolfram demonstrations
project at demonstrations at Wolfram
comm here you can browse through
demonstrations by topic or search for
demonstrations by keyword and when you
found a demonstration that you liked you
can download that demonstration to use
as an example or download the Wolfram
language code use to create the
demonstration and customize it to your
needs
let's create a new section cell we'll go
up to format in style and click section
so there's another way to do that again
this time we'll call it working with
data
now we've already looked at how to
access computable data from Wolfram
Alpha using freeform input now I want to
show you how to use your own data sets
for calculation as well as importing and
exporting as well so let's go ahead and
import some data from a webpage so we're
gonna use the same data file so we're
doing the same thing go ahead and in a
new cell type import with the capital I
and then square brackets what you want
to import this is a web page so we're
going to type quotes and then HTTP colon
slash slash dub-dub-dub hands-on start
comm and then forward slash the file
name is example data scores txt in
quotes and then we're going to type
comma and then we're gonna tell
Mathematica to import this as a data
file so we'll type quotes data quote
close the brace close the bracket and go
ahead and import this and you should get
a list of ordered triples of students
names and their test scores now some
things you may want to do is to extract
certain parts of data so in Mathematica
we can use the part function so we'll
type part with a capital P and then
we'll say this file name the the what we
have called the the variable is data 1
and then we're going to say comma 1 to
return the first part of this data which
is Joe Smith in 94 now another way to
enter this in a keyboard shortcut way is
to say take data 1 and then I'm going to
do two brackets and then the first part
so one and then close the two brackets
and then we get the exact same thing so
these are two ways to say the same thing
now what if we want to say show me the
first part of the so take the first part
and then show me the third element of
that first part so we'll type data 1
open square brackets and then 1 to be
the first part and then the third
element so 3 and then close the brackets
and we get back the test score of 94 or
if we
see the third entity in all of the parts
we can cite we can type data one open
bracket open bracket and then all so
show me all parts and then comma three
to show me the third entity in all parts
hit shift enter and we get all those
test scores back as a list we can also
take those test scores we just got and
then find the numerical approximation of
the mean for example of the previous
output so I'm going to type capital in
which means numerically approximate open
square bracket I'm going to use the
function mean so define the average in
an open square bracket and the percent
sign means of the last output so I say
numerically approximate the mean at the
last output closed the two brackets hit
shift enter and we see that average is
eighty eight point four now in a new
cell let's go ahead and make a new
variable called data two and we're going
to import another file so let's go ahead
and type import and in open square
brackets in quotes example data slash 50
states dot txt and then again we need to
import that as a data file not just a
big blob of text so we're going to say
import its data file and then semicolon
means suppress the output so I don't
want to see all 50 states I just want to
see in a new line so hit the enter key
it showed me the first so first open
square bracket data to close square
bracket hit shift enter and that has now
imported the 50 states in I've asked for
just the first element of that data
which is Alabama so mathematic has
returned the proper answer to us it's
Alabama but Alabama is just a string
there's no actual knowledge attached to
that but there is a way in Mathematica
to get information or get results with
knowledge attached and that's with the
function called semantic import instead
of just import so let's make a new
variable called data 3 and we're going
to use set that equal to semantic import
and we're going to import that same file
as above but this time we don't need to
tell Mathematica to import this data it
on its own so let's go ahead and type a
semicolon to suppress that output and it
will say show me the first element of
data three with this new semantic import
function attached this time you'll see
returned is Alabama comma United States
with this orange box around it so
Mathematica has connected to our server
it's found some additional information
about Alabama and you can notice that if
you look at the suggestions bar you can
see some of the pieces of data are now
at your disposal
things like demographics labor labor
force earnings of people in Alabama and
when you select demographics and choose
population Mathematica then returns for
you the population of Alabama which you
can now use in your future calculations
as well
to make a new section cells let's go
ahead and use that cell insertion
assistant that little plus sign we're
gonna choose other style of text in
click section and then we're going to
call this section presentations now the
beauty of using slideshows in
Mathematica is that all of your text
calculations graphics and manipulates
are all in a single place and they all
retain their interactivity so as you're
presenting the info in the slideshow you
can interact with these manipulates or
change make changes on the fly so let's
go ahead and go back up to pallets and
open the slideshow pallet instead and
from here you can create a new slideshow
so and then you can select the template
you want to use but we've already put a
bunch of work into our current notebook
so let's instead create a slideshow from
our existing document now after clicking
the button to create a slideshow from
the existing document you will see a
prompt where it lets you choose whether
you want the slide brakes to be inserted
let's have slides created after the
title and each of the section cells and
then click insert mathematica then
creates these slides which you can see
on the screen so let's go ahead and say
we want to insert a slide below the
title cell click underneath the title
and click insert and blank slide and
then if you want to remove that slide go
ahead and select the cell bracket
containing the entire slide and click
delete now right now you're in working
mode when you are ready to present your
slideshow you can go to the slideshow
palette and under settings click view
environment and change it from working
to slideshow once in the slideshow you
can now use the arrows to move back and
forth between your slides and on the far
left is a drop down which tells you
which slide you're on and lets you
quickly jump to the slide of your choice
in all of your slides retain their
interactivity so if someone in the
audience asked a question
you can make changes to any calculation
and reevaluate then you can discuss the
results and which makes your
presentation much more dynamic and
engaging so I hope you have found this
hands-on start video useful to get
started with Mathematica again my name
is cliff Hastings and my email address
is cliff at hands-on starts dot-com this
presentation was created from the book
the hands-on start to mathematic book
it's available on Amazon either in
paperback or Kindle versions if you
would like a book version to assist you
with your start or refresher to
Mathematica if you have any questions or
comments for me please feel free to send
me an email
I'll do my best to help or get you the
assistance that you need and best of
luck and I can't wait to see what you do
with Mathematica